On the weekend, I realized I'd left my favorite sweater in the trunk of the car,
so I came down from my apartment, stood in line by the curb outside,
and waited while a truck delivered gas to the station across from the shopping center.
On vacation, I promised my neighbor I'd organize a program of activities for the kids,
including swimming at the local recreation center,
soccer on the field by the meter-high fence,
and a trip to the theater in the downtown area.
Before traveling, I wrote a check to pay for the jewelry repair,
checked the schedule for the trains,
and practiced my presentation for the defense of our proposal at City Council.
At 4.30, I bought a bag of chips and a cookie from the store,
threw the trash in the garbage can,
and headed home to clean up the yard before the fall weather got worse.
Later, I reserved a table at a cozy restaurant,
made sure the license for the car was current,
and told my mom I'd call her from the highway rest stop on the way back from the hospital.